how much would you pay me for a date
yeah that's correct don't get too
excited let's start with something five
million
no
520 don't push it one dollar that was
well the value of a date may seem
insignificant to you now
but a date given in sadaka will be as
heavy as a mountain for you on your
scale of good deeds when you meet allah
subhanahu ta'ala the prophet peace be
upon him said save yourself from the
fire even if you give the half a date in
charity listen carefully do you know how
humongous and raging the hellfire is
guys imagine half a date that you give
for the sake of allah in charity
what might be the reason that you do not
enter the fire islam net is raising
funds to establish a masjid and
community center in norway and they
urgently need your support if you give a
small sabaka like we said half a date in
charity it will divert you from entering
the hellfire and if you're not going to
go into the hellfire where else would
allah put you except this jannah this
donation will be a sadakajare for you so
the more you're able to give the bigger
share you should want to have in this
project because every person that comes
a step closer to allah through your
contribution you will inshallah be
reaping the rewards for it every person
who prays there every kid that learns
about islam every youngster that
memorizes the quran all of this and so
much more can be on your scale of good
deeds click the link and donate what you
can and share the video for even extra
rewards
[Music]